In this first of two concluding lectures.
I would like to go back and revisit some of the important points for which we do
not yet have answers.
These are the open questions.
Can we develop evolution proof antimicrobial therapies?
Can we switch the host pathogen interaction from resistance to tolerance does
very owns evolve when leaky vaccines are used,
can we treat cancer by slowing somatic evolution?
What are the ultimate reasons for susceptibility to cancer?
Do early,
late light hit life history tradeoffs help us to find new treatments for aging
and what is the role of parent of origin in printing in metal disease?
First,
can we develop evolution proof therapies?
We know the resistance evolves rapidly.
Every time a new drug or insecticide is introduced,
we're losing the chemical arms race for evolutionary reasons.
Evolution proof options for bacterial infections includes phage therapy and
disrupting public goods for insect vectors.
Options include pesticides,
that accolade in life.
Another open issue is whether we can switch the patient's response from
resistance to tolerance.
We need to understand the conditions under which it pays to tolerate an
infection rather than resistant.
The trade offs in which tolerance tolerances evolved so that we can judge when
to promote it and the mechanisms that mediate the transition from resistance and
various lens to tolerance and commensalism.
It's quite a research agenda.
What does inflammation trade off with and can we modulate that tradeoff to
reduce endothelial damage and atherosclerosis?
That would be a very interesting approach to cardiovascular disease.
Yeah.
The next issue is whether virulence really does evolve when a leaky vaccine is
used.
We know that in very increases when these leaky vaccines are used in mice and
chickens,
will that increased virulence evolve?
When we use leaky vaccines for HPV and for malaria in humans,
we need monitoring programs to measure the virulence of circulating strains so
that we can assess the magnitude of any effects and we need to develop
treatments for the more virulent strains that are are anticipated to evolve.
Yeah.
Can we treat cancer by slowing somatic evolution?
We know that adaptive therapy does extend the lifespan of mice suffering from
cancer.
One clinical trial of this idea is now underway in humans.
We urgently need to understand the potential benefits to patients who would
otherwise die from failed chemotherapy.
Okay.
What are the ultimate reasons that we are susceptible to cancer?
We have preliminary comparative evidence suggesting that more invasive,
pleasant Taishan increases the risk of metastatic cancer.
We need to understand the mechanical bases of that effect and to explore them to
develop strategies for preventing and treating metastatic cancer.
In other words,
we may need to look for clues in a model system in which embryos or pre pre
embryos are implanting in the endometrium to understand the mechanical bases of
myth metastases
do early late life history tradeoff suggest treatments for aging.
For example,
the target of the rapid mice signaling network mediates performance early and
late in life.
The late life effects may include risks of all the risk of Alzheimer's disease.
Rapha mice and supplements do extend life in mice,
but they do not appear to do so in humans.
However,
the idea that prompted that research was more general.
What mechanisms mediate the tradeoffs between early and late life.
By investigating that more general question,
we may get at new treatments for aging,
other mechanisms must exist and finding them could suggest more successful
interventions.
Another open issue is what actually is the role of parent of origin imprinting
in mental disease.
We know that the deletions of parent of origin imprinted genes do produce
syndromes of heightened risk of autism or schizophrenia depending on which
parental copies deleted.
That's the Angelman Prader,
Willi contrast,
and others.
There is correlative support for this idea that comes from a large scale study
of disease risk.
In Denmark,
we need independent tests.
If the results are confirmed,
then we need to identify the mechanisms that mediate that risk.
So to summarize,
evolutionary medicine is a new field in which some issues are supported by
reliable results and others remain open.
Some of the open issues are really quite serious.
They deserve immediate attention and investment.